I'm see Kayla right now based in
Kathmandu Nepal I was trained as a civil
engineer urban planner then I did a bit
of public administration and law and I
have been writing on social and
political issues of Nepal for now almost
25 years a columnist and a commentator
basically but also speak to students or
intellectuals interested in Nepal
whenever possible I after the changes in
1990 which was the restauration of
multiparty democracy in Nepal I thought
that there are many good engineers in
Nepal but the level of public commentary
could do with a bit of more effort and I
thought it I may have it may sound
hubris t'know but I thought maybe I had
something to add to the discussion going
on and I started with a column called
fifth column and then independent weekly
it is it has been closed since then then
shifted from there to daily Kathmandu
post and then to Nepali Times
Himmel cover Patrika Nepali Himalaya
Times in Nepali few pieces in
Kanchipuram Nepali and then right now I
am with república daily and I meanwhile
I have contributed for Himmel South
Asian for over a decade so a lot of
writing yes in 1990 after the
restoration of multiparty democracy we
had a press which which was a culture
eyes in two basic streams one what we
call back then the missing journalism
which was working for promotion of
democracy then another was apologist of
Kings Authority
in room so I call that Commission
journalism so we had nothing in between
missing journalism and Commission
journalism and I thought that probably
now that democracy has come we needed
what could be called compassion
journalism which is not truly missing
journalism but still sympathetic towards
democratic causes the poor and oppressed
of Nepal but certainly not commissioned
journalism so this kind of compassion
journalism I thought was a slot which
was empty and it needed some work before
1990 there were only two major
newspapers one in English and one in
Nepali the nepali one was Gorka Patra
the english ponderizing nepal as a
student we were told that you should
read rising Nepal to learn how not to
write English and you should read work
hapara to learn how to write Nepali
other than that it both papers had no
news value because they were kind of
propaganda instruments of the regime
back then semi semi authoritarian regime
kings authoritarian regime after 1990
restoration of democracy there was
sudden openness and Nepal's media scene
became vibrant because Constitution
guaranteed the right to free expression
and laws were made very liberal so a
private sector newspapers came in and
after 1990 these two newspapers they
exist even now but they are limited they
have become kind of niche publication
serving the needs of advertisement for
government and you know openings in the
government whereas for news and views
you go into the private sector
publication so both coexist
chick buys although the government
publications have begun to lose their
relevance in the post 1990 environment
one was the print media of course which
was easier to handle because print media
doesn't require anything more than a
printing press and paper and for
journalists ability to write and report
whereas for radio electronic media for
radio and television investment is
slightly higher so private sector
investment was slow to come in but once
he started coming in there was no
stopping to stays where before 1990 we
had all of one radio station now if you
take into account FM radio stations we
have almost more than 350 actually all
over the country and for a population of
about 26 27 million we have fourteen
television channels and some more in the
pipeline so television channels of
course serve
usually the population with access to
electricity and those who can afford a
television set but radio sets cheap you
can buy a chinese-made radio set for
maybe about $75 apiece which is less
than a US dollar so almost the radio has
almost 75 more than 75% of anybody's
have access to radio programs and these
more than 350 FM stations are located
all over the country they broadcast in
different languages to just keep you one
example from my in my home town alone
which has a population of less than
50,000 we have about five FM stations
three of them in local language two in
Nepali which is the national language
and they have programs in both puri
another
language of Nepal then few other
languages in addition to him the program
of the BBC Nepali program of the BBC so
media scene is very very active and
radio is a happening place with some
problems of course the curse of
abundance because there are more radio
stations then there are trained
journalists so quality of programs
leaves something to be desired a lot of
the time but it's happening seen when
Maoist insurgency started the risk was
only from the insurgents but then we had
this period of emergency and the king
took direct control and we had mmm
you know military editors in newsrooms
and newspapers were reduced to
publishing news about frogs and crows
and trees radio programs we're social
evils the practice of dowry for example
all the child marries hard political
news was almost blacked out and life as
a commentator was difficult because you
know we would be questioned by the
military or by the Maoist so the risk
was from two sides and even after the
end of insurgency it is still not back
to the vibrant days of early 1990s
because there is still fear from several
armed groups and government to has yet
to learn to be fully tolerant as it was
in the early days of 1990 so it's kind
of a transitional period for media
practitioners in the problem Krishna
scene for example was a journalist
sympathetic towards Maoist cause and he
was made to disappear and actually a
less to have been killed in custody
another critique of the Mazda Khmer
Thapa
he was taken under custody by the MA
and recently some of most careless
admitted that they buried him alive and
that case is being investigated now so
both sides were equally repressive of
journalists and many journalists lost
their lives actually in those days it
was says that Nepal was one of the most
difficult places to be a journalist in
the world and it has improved slightly
but even now Nepal actually falls among
ten most difficult places in the world
to be journalists we became the
journalists in Nepal we became kind of
more as an activist some of us having
our sympathy with the mouse the small
part many of us with democratic cause
and some of us even apologist of the
royal military regime so it was a
divided scene and once the profession is
divided it it becomes weak and probably
we were not as strong a force as we
could have been had we kept our
impartiality intact and work in unison
for peace rather than giving air to our
prejudices and adding fuel to the fire
of armed conflict so that is a
reflection but where I think Nepali
media can be proud is that despite the
challenges it kept working not one radio
station was permanently closed down
television studios were functional
newspaper were still being published
despite all the pressure the the media
scene remained open and that was one of
the few places where sanity could be
seen inside the country so something we
should think about is our impartiality
and something that we can be really
proud of the Nepali media persons can be
proud of is we never cease to work I
have been thinking about this constraint
genes in Nepal see in Nepal we have had
six constitution in almost as many
decades so as far as per decade
Constitution making goes Nepal must rank
first in the world in a lighter vein of
course we had our first constitution in
in the 1940s then the second one in
1950s the third one in 1960 the fourth
one again in 1960 the fifth one in 1990s
and the sixth one after 2006 and I tried
to think why is it that we become so
dissatisfied with a constitution within
ten years and I came to a conclusion
that it could be that we have not been
able to define what it means to be
Nepali
when any Constitution is said to be to
borrow a very famous word for the people
by the people of the people but when you
say people who are these Nepalese people
and then I thought maybe the nationality
question in Nepal is as it unresolved
our kings defined Nepalese as someone
loyal to the crown rather to the country
and even during democratic regime it was
a cultural definition of nationality
rather than political cultural is one
language one religion one people one
race one kind of food one kind of
lifestyle
so this plural nationality which
citizens it sips would encompass I
thought that definition had not yet come
in and that's why this after once unless
you have this nationality question
resolved it's very difficult to go into
you know political ideas like democracy
or social is
so I thought this nationality question
needs to be resolved and I wrote a book
first in Nepali what it nepali ahuna lie
so from Nepali Nepali Nepali was kind of
a cultural idea this one language one
dress one culture one religion idea and
then Nepali is a political idea that you
live in Nepal you may be of any culture
you may speak any language you could be
a Muslim a Christian a Buddhist a Hindu
a Baha'i or whatever but still you can
be good nepali so this accommodative
idea of Nepali nationality I came up
with this monograph actually and then it
had a very wide discussion all over the
country many districts almost forty
forty five districts almost all the top
leaders of Nepal commented upon content
of the book including former prime
minister parameter IANA Pali Congress
leaders UML leaders Zanna sati leaders
but AC leaders many civil society
activists almost all journalists then
the idea came up that maybe this is an
idea redefining nationality in 21st
century where almost all countries are
going to be multinational in cultural
sense of the term so contents of the
book should come in English as well and
that is how I translated the book in
English in English it's slightly
simplified because I was addressing to a
different kind of audience which was not
very familiar of nuances of Nepalese
reality so the English person is
slightly simplified than the Nepali one
but both books in a way try to create
the ground of Nepal where democracy can
survive where democracy democratic
practices can have a fair plane you see
this definition of nationality basically
two
schools of thought one is that you are
born into a nationality which cannot be
taken away from you
the idea of nationality by blood
another is nationality by soil so in the
country that which in which you are born
you become a citizen my idea was that
probably both of them have their
limitation so this idea of nationality
should be okay
by blood is a way which is a cultural
nationality it should be recognized
recognized because taste for example
takes a long time to go if you are
attached to certain kind of food you
like it language for example the first
language that you learn from your mother
it stays throughout your life even some
of the cultural practices songs for
example so cultural nationality is a
strong force political personality to
the the loyalty to your country of birth
is equally strong because you bathe that
year you drink that water part of that
soil comes into you so that is also very
strong without denying these two you
cultivate a culture of tolerance which
accepts the diversity and essentially it
becomes a political allegiance to
certain Constitution that makes you a
national that particular country so that
is it's a complex argument but I try to
simplify it a little more in Nepali
verson with historic instances from
Nepal how this Nepali idea came up first
from HUS Nepali and then to Gorkhali
and then to Nepali in English versum a
generalized idea of cultural nationality
social nationality and then political
nationality why constitutions fail I
think this is
one of the most challenging questions in
political science constitutions have
failed in Germany for example Weimar
Constitution was said to be one of best
of that time but it could not stop
Hitler from rising through popular
German mandate so that is a question we
have been facing in Nepal also for
example the 1990 Constitution was said
to be one of the best in the world
because it had incorporated best
features of common law of United Kingdom
and the popular mandate of this American
system the best features are both so it
was a hybrid Constitution but said to be
a very ideal from political science
point of the view but contrary to
political science there is something
called politics which works according to
how it relates to ground realities in
that particular country and I my idea in
assessing the failure of question of
1990 was that at the moment of crisis
nobody owned up that document Nepali
Congress and UML two main political
parties they they were instrumental in
its framing but when the Constitution
was under attack none of them stood up
to defend it and why was it
and my observation a quick assessment
was that because people who had not
owned up that document so it's very
important to make people own up a
document that document may not be
perfect what is more important is people
should think that they have made this
constitution it is their constitution
then only they come to defend it so this
is how what Nepal really needs is not
the best Constitution in the world which
has failed but what Nepal needs is a
constitution which all kinds of Nepalese
feel that it reflects their aspiration
it addresses their concern
so that
it is it comes under a crisis which
always happens in any society in any
country then they can stand up and say
that no this is our Constitution will
defend it so that kind of a definition
requires that we need a new document new
mandate I was born in a mightily
speaking family when I went to school I
was taught
Nepali in Hindi medium because most of
my teachers were educated in India and
Nepali was a required language because
it was the national language then in the
university I did most of my reading in
English and since nepali was the
official language i ended up working in
nepali and in english most of my books
are including play and other books in
nepali and in english but i had a column
for quite a while in Hindi and of course
I've written a book in mightily as well
so these four languages I ended up being
equally conversant but since most of the
work needs to be done in Nepali and
English so that continues to be made two
major languages
Nepal's now this Nepal's linguistic
diversity it's really fascinating with
27 million people we have more than 102
recognized languages by the Census
authorities so even if you discount
languages that are spoken by less than
1% of the population we still end up
having seven eight main languages now we
do need some kind of a lingua franca to
connect all these language speakers due
to investments made in Nepali over last
250 years it has established itself as a
lingua franca so we cannot get away from
Nepali whether you like it or not some
linguistic campaign
against it but that's a reality you can
turn away from because in that
investment is a national investment you
cannot run away from English as well
because it has emerged as an
international language in addition to
that our close neighbor is India where
for all practical purposes official
language is English that is so in our
other neighboring countries such as in
Bangladesh or in Pakistan all over South
Asia actually and we have had
connections with United Kingdom which is
very long so English retains it place
third language could be Hindi because
that is emerging as lingua franca of
South Asia due to Hindi movies or
television programmes or whatever then
of course there are languages different
languages of the country so in my book I
argue that essentially something
patterned after India especially South
India what we need is a three language
policy at the center you have English
Nepali and one of the regional languages
when you go to now that will will be
going into a federal system so
provincial government where you have
Nepali and one regional language and
many local languages
then you go to the local government unit
where you have Nepali one regional
language and dominant local language of
the region this way we'll be able to
manage linguistic diversity of the
country and this will be I think a
contribution where languages are dying
all over the world
almost they say linguistic genocide so
it will be slightly more expensive but
worth the effort because it will
integrate the country in a commonality
well they still have their distinctive
identity is intact plus it will save
several languages from dying down so
this is one of the proposals that I
make in my new definition of Nepali
ahuna lie or the ways of being Nepalese
Nepal has not been getting the attention
it requires I think mainly because it is
surrounded by two of the largest country
of the world to the east west and south
we have India a billion plus country and
to the north even though it's Tibet
Autonomous Region but essentially
People's Republic of China which is
another billion-plus country when you
are surrounded by billion plus countries
you tend to forget that 27 million
people makes Nepal one of the 50 biggest
countries in the world out of 200 or so
UN member countries so Nepal in itself
is not as small as it appears that is by
size of Rafi or population it's one of
the 50 largest country of the world
second if you were to draw diagonal
lines on a map of Asia you'll find that
Nepal is close to the center so apart
from being a transitional space between
the great Indian civilization and
thiboutot Chinese civilization
and also the East Asian civilization of
Burma Thailand and the West Asian
civilization from which extends from
Persia Arabia through Afghanistan
Kashmir so it's a meeting point of
cultures and civilizations that is its
cultural civilizational significance the
third sociological significance because
it has got so much diversity that it
becomes some kind of a political social
laboratory where you can observe things
from very close and then of course this
political challenge in Nepal multi of
multiple transitions from monarchy to
Republic from Hindu religious state to a
secular state from a plant controlled
economy to open economy
unified unitary society to a plural
society from a unitary system to a
federal system so no matter what kind of
political experiment interests you it is
being tried out in Nepal and it's
lessons will be useful for you know
anywhere in the world
because essentially if you human beings
are political animal they are political
animal anywhere if they are social
animal they are social animal anywhere
and the fifth point which I think should
attract world attention towards Nepal is
the definition of democracy till now has
been very much based upon the print
culture when this Benedict Anderson's
idea about print making nationality is
based then we had radio culture which
kind of improved this democratic
practices we went to television culture
internet culture now you have this
social media which is likely to affect
practice of democracy and that in a new
setting you in a new setting you see
impacts more clearly so this observation
how it works out in Nepal it will have
useful nations a lessons for almost any
country in the world so I think this is
why Nepal should get more attention from
scholars from students for from we were
interested in climate change or
graphically because we have Himalayas
and the plains or social changes
cultural changes political changes it's
a fascinating place it's one of the most
interesting times to be in Nepal